what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video
um sent to me when one of my subscribers
titled did i make a mistake leaving him
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of
all my daily videos all right so
what do you got on the subject so i just
wanted to
say that while i do believe that there
are some men that will wait
most men will not and that's just the
fact
i have been that person who has waited
90 days i've
waited however many days um because of
my mom
reading the steve harvey book and
whatever and you know
my mom and my sister giving me advice
and
i have learned that it really does not
work
um although it does with some men
i think um certain men with
specific types of morals who are looking
for a specific type of woman
they are willing to wait what kind of
men are you talking about
a man who um
sees women as a prize
or a man who has options a lot of
options for women
who might choose this woman to be the
one that he courts
and then these women to be the women
that he
okay i want to be i want to be saying as
morals you said
morals well yes because some
men for a specific kind of woman we'll
wait
i would agree i would agree with that
like certain especially men in the
church they'll wait
they'll like a lot of guys have met the
church will wait okay
even for girls that have lost like their
virginity year i've had like hooked up
with other guys i've met a lot of guys
that will as long as
the change in her is actually genuine
okay but i like to get down
granular morals how do you determine a
man's morals
based upon are you talking about men who
are christians no
not at all okay so what do we what do we
talk about a man's
morals a man who
sees a woman as someone
because morals are just right and morals
are right and wrong and that has nothing
to do
with seeing a woman so what you're
talking about is you're almost talking
about a man who pedestalizes a woman
puts on a pedestal but also a man who
sees
the cherry as the prize okay but where's
the cherry
the cherry is you know where is it
located
okay no ma'am where is the cherry
located on a dessert
oh at the top at the top thank you it's
at the top of the pedestal
okay so that's that's where it is a man
who pedestalizes women
puts them up but let me ask
what what culture of competitive
successful men
put women ahead of men
i don't know that any do because there's
a formula
for disaster
putting women at the top because i don't
think it's a good idea to tell women to
have
because this is the thing they'll talk
about in the atmosphere that they don't
want girls with high body counts but
then they'll also tell
guys to like leave girls um
if they won't sleep with you right away
because they're not interested
um and i think it's unwise to
not see the benefit and like getting to
know someone before you get
physical just my personal opinion the
sure way to crumble a society
so the moral thing to do if you want a
society to continue
is to put who on top
right so why play games with
the the thing that needs to be on top
listen i don't think it's a game i think
it's just wanting to be wise with who
you sleep with
at first you know if you you wanted
someone to come on and say why they
think you're crazy and they don't agree
with you but the more i sit here and the
more i'm
obviously listening and thinking about
my own experiences
it's not a good idea to play those types
of games and that's why i've told my mom
you know i'm a human being and you know
granted i wait
a long time many many months
up years to engage in that type of
activity but that's because i
i don't date for a long time okay so
how old are you 38 i'm i'm well past the
danger zone
so do you plan on so have you been
married
no engaged twice but never married no
you know what i say sisters are the
queens of being engaged man
being engaged if if we can count
engagements as marriages i wonder i want
to know if he's like
but okay so you've been engaged do you
ever want to have children
biological children well yeah only if
i marry someone and he wants to have so
what i got to ask the question but yes
what i asked the question
and i'm trying to put this in a delicate
way as possible but
at 38 years old
why should anybody wait years to have
sex with you
oh no no no no for months no no no no no
oh okay i don't think months is that
long at the time
like genuinely i think there's a benefit
of getting to know somebody before you
have sex with them say it because you
said
because you're talking about everybody
else and what i thought i heard you say
was
but for me i wait a long time no
in between people like i oh okay yes no
me
i wait a very long time like i'm not
going to
wait a very long time for what to have
sex
yes so when you meet a man you wait a
long time
depending on the man but um
man that's what you keep saying no
that's what we keep hearing slow down
break
breathe breathe breathe breathe breathe
if you meet them if you meet how long
have you typically waited from the time
you met a man
to the time you guys were first intimate
the shortest probably
honestly the shortest probably i don't
know a week or two
the longest um
no more than about three months
okay and and this
and so that's a vast range and that's
what frustrates men
there is no logical sense to a man
that you could say one man has to wait
up to 90 days
and one guy doesn't even have to wait a
week
men on the marketplace look at that as
i'm going to buy a car
yeah and one dealership is but this is
the hard part is that
um i do think some women learn from
their mistakes and don't want to
continue the same cycle
um so it's tough because i do see
the men's perspective but i also
know a lot of women that realized like
what they were doing and the results
that got them so they decided to change
like what they were doing
um so i could see both sides offering it
for a hundred dollars
and another dealership is offering up
for a hundred thousand dollars
men are price sensitive and we are
cost benefit calculators so in your own
example
you've just validated why men are so
frustrated with women on the marketplace
because you can talk
and have these things and steve harvey
and this and that my mother
but in your own day-to-day life 30
90 days to a week but at the end of the
day
no matter what your calculus is whatever
kind of interaction you want to have
with the man
do you currently have it
right now yeah she wouldn't be on the
show if she had it
are you will you are you in the process
of getting it within the next six
months doubtful
then what you're doing isn't working and
you're almost
40.
so you talk to your mother and it's
where's your father
oh my dad my dad they're still married
okay but what i'm understanding is
you're
you're attractive woman but why why no
man
um the simple answer is there's two
simple answers
and i'm sure every woman and many men
say the same thing
pickiness the second simple answer is oh
no look at his face
look at his faces again what do you
gotta be picky for i
actually really am interested in like
for real for real
they're it just not it's not
reciprocated um
to the point where like we'll date and
everything will be fine and then
all of a sudden
they're gone or i'm gone okay oh no no
no
let's talk about the ones where you said
you just told two different things the
kind of meaning you say you're really
interested in it's not reciprocated
yes uh well it not reciprocated means
it's not coming back with them so you
just told a story where
they leave and you leave that's
confusing
well or i leave because i have done the
same thing
so it's not reciprocated from you
that yes because of something very
specific that might happen that makes me
become unattractive to the person
very cool you know why is why is it why
is why is dating why is getting with the
man so
complex this is like calculus three
and it shouldn't be no it shouldn't
there is a person that i was dating
that seems to be coming back around but
i don't i don't really know if that's
the case i don't know
why were you engaged you engaged twice
i i was engaged twice somebody dropped
to a knee
presented a ring in public and asked you
for your hand in marriage
yes almost three times but twice and who
broke off the engagement the first time
i did who broke off the engagement the
second time i did
why did you accept the ring the first
time because he was my
best friend my and that didn't stop
after he gave you the ring
oh no it no it didn't stop so why'd you
break it off
if it was good enough to accept the ring
why was it not good enough to go through
with the marriage
um well uh the reason
is because he and i
were not compatible but
what does that mean but you accepted the
ring that is correct
so you weren't sexually compatible that
is correct
how would you say sexually compatible
you know if you see
here's the problem having too many
here's the problem with sex before
marriage
you wouldn't know that if you for your
virgin there's no sexual compatibility
see you're per you're you're
a different kind of perfect example
38 year old woman who should
70 80 years ago you'd have been married
a long time ago but it has become so
complex i mean you're accepting
engagement from people you're not
sexually compatible with
this doesn't work that doesn't work i'm
too picky and so forth you know where
that ends up being is ma'am
oh look at her face she's like ah she's
right
that's what that ends up being buy a dog
die alone that's what this ends up in
because at 40 years old almost 40 years
old
you become more difficult
not less have you had
therapy yet no
i think you will be wise why
uh me excuse me define demand
yes that's why i need therapy to find a
man oh you need therapy period
well why is that okay let's stop right
there seriously man
why why is therapy insulting
to so many black women like and you're a
woman why is that insulting to you
no i'm not insulted at all i wanted to
be a therapist i i was just asking
is are you saying look at kevin you're
so well you need something
you need something about that you need
something
because what you're doing ain't working
and what i'm listening to man what i'm
listening to ma'am is a woman who's been
engaged
to my best friend such and so forth you
know all these things and you got a man
to the point to waste his time money and
resource
to the point to where he was involved
with you enough to where he bought a
ring you accepted
and you broke it see if we started
judging you women like you judge men
and put you on the don't date them girls
site your face will be posted out
plastered all over it
don't deal with it listen man listen man
listen
you broke off two engagements one from a
best friend
and you say because the dick wasn't good
i'm sorry such a bad reason oh my gosh
that is such a bad reason to break up
break up with somebody i'm sorry but
you can you can learn that stuff that is
a hundred percent
learned like you could teach someone i'm
not even trying to get too into it
because i feel awkward as hell like
talking about that stuff
but that is such a terrible terrible
reason to break it off with somebody
if you have somebody that is kind caring
compassionate
loyal you know if he has every other
quality that you are looking for like i
don't know what it is for her
but if he has all of that and you say oh
he can't make me
you know come or whatever and i won't
teach him
that's your own fault that you're single
because what if men
said that about women like oh she
doesn't blow me well enough or she
doesn't
like her [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] you know women
would freak out
they would freak out like that is so
messed up that you were going to marry a
guy oh my gosh this is making me so mad
you were gonna marry a guy marry him
and you said that because he he
he didn't have sex with you the right
way so what you could you literally have
the rest of your life to learn that
oh my gosh that's a trash ass reason
and why'd you break up the second one
bad dick again uh no
i don't want her i what i don't want him
to see
well honestly because he was
um i could not learn anything from him
i'll say that i was unable to
learn from him what do you what do you
need to
you got youtube what are you going to
learn did not challenge me
intellectually and that was a major
problem for me
we became engaged too quickly he told me
he proposed to me because he
thought i was about to leave him which
was kind of true so i made a mistake
i just made a mistake and we were only
engaged for two months
i mean how long were we guys together um
we were only together for six months but
we worked together before
so we were we'd known each other for a
year
and how were you when this happened
uh twenty
four or five i don't remember it was a
long time i've been engaged
for a while the third almost engaged
hold up hold up
so was the first time you were engaged i
was
in college but he was my high school
sweetheart
but i i'm so so hold on hold on
wait how did she if you're only in
college and you dated him from high
school how would you know that you're
not sexually compatible
so you were engaged to a high school
slash college sweetheart
but you and not him together because you
guys weren't physically compatible
trash ass reason but okay then a guy you
knew for a year
but he didn't challenge you
intellectually um
what did he do for a living
i'm in education now what did he do for
a living oh what did he do
uh he the second one we were
working for um we worked for a so you're
both teachers
no no no no um i'm not a teacher but
he we worked for a youth a residential
treatment facility for kids
okay and you're in education what do you
do now
i i am in administration
what did i tell you guys black that's
the reason that the education is so
expensive it's all the administrators
i swear to god women are married to the
system
that's your husband put him in place and
put him in charge of
whatever i said last broadcast that's
what they are
because you're getting rid of men
because of sexual incompatibility and a
lot of women say well that's an
important part okay
then the man uh that last man you were
both doing a similar job so he could he
was a stable man though financially
as stable as you at least well
we it was there wasn't a lot of money in
that job i didn't say i said as stable
as you at least
that's correct you're right because if
you were in it he was in it and you were
stable right
yes i was so because he wasn't he wasn't
what you're showing man is the standard
a black woman
has for a black man to be married you
damn near have to be a god
yeah yeah he's he's spitting facts
he's spitting facts because
i don't know i don't have a single
friend that i can think of i'm gonna i'm
gonna preface
because sometimes i say i don't know
anybody on this channel and then i think
of somebody later
but i don't know a single friend that
broke up with their boyfriend because of
sexual incompatibility genuinely i don't
know a single person
go back and just man we just had a
conversation
you said you couldn't learn anything
from it
that's just a nice what'd your mother
learn from your father
oh well a lot my dad's i can't
i can't honestly tell you specifics but
how to be a wife
um and a best friend and i just know my
dad is very very smart he's a provider
he's i mean you got any siblings i have
a i have two sisters
are they married one is married and
one is engaged and
this is her i don't know third
engagement
it's yeah it's not i mean it's i mean i
don't find this
i think it's kind of sad that so many of
our sisters are so
damn complex and difficult to weigh
difficult to wear and difficult to keep
when the black community divorce rate is
approaching towards 60
and 80 of the voices are filed by women
so you're already at the least married
you're the most difficult to get married
and i'm going to say i'm gonna make a
proclamation you've heard the black
women are the most educated
um and that's that what it really means
is you're most enrolled
so i'm going to say you're the least
married but i'm going to also say you
the most engaged
you're the most engaged i i don't meet a
group of group of women who've been
engaged one two three four five four
times clearly if you're single
older actually yeah he's probably right
he's probably
it is not uncommon to meet a black woman
who's 40 years old and engaged at least
a couple times
it's very common and i'm talking about
full-out engagement
man drops
that's that's that's not cool because at
the end of the day
you're not getting the outcome you want
it because your life is supposed to mean
something
and at 38 years old
what's your life going to mean if you go
through it by yourself
until the grave i have a plan
for okay i become 40 around 44 45
to adopt two children older children oh
so you're gonna be a single parent
yes probably so you're gonna purposely
go in to do the one thing that you know
gives children statistically the worst
outcome damn
okay but some of those kids end up with
no parents so i mean it's better than
nothing
my dog is snoring i'm sorry um how many
kids you got
i don't have children your dog your dog
is snoring
yeah i can hear her i don't know okay
well that makes sense see her husband is
the building
you think your godfather is crazy do you
have a phd
no a master's masters okay i'm a phd
ma'am you're an attractive woman you
have a beautiful eye but come on man
this is
you gotta know that your non-black
female counterparts are not this
difficult
okay i'm not gonna speak on generalities
but
i don't know any girls um
that have ended it with a guy because of
that i don't i agree with you
and both of them both are your sisters
no i was gonna say both of my line
sisters are married
delta no i'm not a delta
okay aka yeah sigma gamma rho
yes why why ask me that
because you said your line sister's name
before i
so my point my point is ma'am that when
you're a little girl
i don't think you likely thought i'll be
a dog mom adopting two kids at 45 and
that'll be
the testament of my life no
why is that good enough now why is that
what you're willing to settle for
so let me say something let me move you
to the side move you to the side
ladies why are you you always talk about
what man you ain't willing to settle for
ain't gonna settle angle son
why are you willing to settle for death
by yourself ladies
why are you willing to settle for dying
alone
why i think it's because they think that
there might be something better
and so it's not necessarily that they
think they're picking dying alone but
it's
they think they're
that someone better is out there for
them why why
the only group of women on the planet
who is willing to be strong
independent i don't need no man because
i ain't gonna settle but you'll settle
for dying
alone write it down trade market
can i say one thing sure go ahead we're
back to you now
oh go ahead that was an aside go ahead
people who have i'm just being on i'm
not making this up
people who have who have dated me
and or my friends and people
my friends who are in relationships and
they're always like you are so cool and
and the guys that date
you are so cool you make me laugh you're
this you're that
and it's like after they date me
they go to an ex
or somebody else and then it's like they
get married to that person
yeah because nobody wants to marry the
cool chick they want to marry a wife
damn ah oh that hurt a little bit
oh that hurt me a little bit
uh well first off you're extremely picky
so your rank will probably rank rather
low in agreeableness
i am i am very agreeable i am uh okay
and i know amazing i like how she's
arguing
what am i in agreeableness i'm at the
70th percentile i took jordan peterson's
personality test like two years ago
i think it was at the 70th percentile
fun fact i used to
hate hate hate the fact that i was
agreeable because
i was in sports and that does not help
you in sports
like in sports you are overlooked for
captains positions you're overlooked for
all this stuff
so i genuinely was so mad that i wasn't
the type to like take charge in a room
and like
you know run drills and all this stuff
but when i
started like thinking about it more i
realized that
that's the reason people like me is that
i'm easy to talk to you guys will even
see like i can have people on my channel
that i 100 like don't agree with
anything they say on
at all and i get along with them
because i know how to get along with
people um
okay you believe if i ask the guys you
okay have you ever interviewed your exes
interviewed them yes i've asked because
i'm cool with
my experiences okay what is it like to
be with you then
i'm cool fun it's fun
damn it i get that i'm fun too a lot not
just for guys just for people
in general damn
uh-huh so a guy so a guy that you
so if i interviewed your ex your first
ex-fiance he would tell me being with
you is what
my first experience he would say being
with me was amazing
and right until you dumped him he no he
still
he would still say that okay and then
the second guy
would say being with you is what
fun okay then the guy you the guy you
may wait 90 days how long were you guys
together
uh there's been more than one um but
the last one
probably no more than a year you're with
a guy for a year
once okay why and why did you leave that
relationship
um it was kind of just kind of a waste
okay a waste meaning what i'm a waste
meaning what you
so a waste meaning what your your your
purpose in life
is to i'm this going to be tough man but
at 38 years old
you're doing something in the youth in
the youth position or youth what
my job yeah your yes
i'm in education right now okay you're
in education so
it's not like you're solving the riemann
hypothesis
why does a man need to be all these
great and wonderful things other than a
man
because i'm all these great and
wonderful things [ __ ]
damn no you're not you're a normal
average everyday woman see that's the
problem
so many so many so many women
pedestalizing no
man
where'd you go to college hbcu lemoine
on college
okay what puts you what makes you great
and wonderful
and in the top one percent of all women
i am not in the top percent of it so
that means
so you're great and wonderful and all
these things what what what in your life
makes you say that you're that i do
believe
this is the benefit of growing up with
low self-esteem
i never thought i was great and
wonderful
i swear to god sorry i'm live i'm a
great person
doesn't mean you're not that you can be
a good person but when i say it's so
great and wonderful and everything else
that put
go back to that cherry on top and that's
how you think of yourself and that's why
it's difficult for women like yourself
to be with a man
because you always need to be above a
man in the middle okay do you know what
my
biggest dating detriment is i think i'm
tall
and this is not an invitation for you
people in the comments to tell me what
else it is
this is not but yeah it's definitely
being tall
i do not understand girls that are five
five and wouldn't date a guy
that's below six foot like i'm six foot
i probably date a guy that's five times
like genuinely it's my biggest detriment
man who above you won't deal with you
because we're on top of that kind of
[ __ ] honestly we don't know what you're
saying
well the thing is ma'am and i'm and see
this is
this the kind of air i don't know why
that's such a bad thing
most people are average against an
entitlement we've we
this is what men think of it the the
full of your selfness that so many i'm
all a lady is independent
i mean that stuff in our culture has the
women thinking they're better than the
men
smarter than the men above the men but
you're the most
unmarried most engaged
most enrolled
and ain't nobody marrying black women
nobody
bradley and mayor keith and enrique
they're like how can you even deal with
this
because at the end of the day are you a
christian i don't know if you are not an
ask
huh yes okay then if you're a christian
the woman's purpose on the planet is a
man
your job is to be a health meat go forth
be fruitful and multiply
that's the commandment see we're the
most we're the most
christian unchristian people if black
women actually acted like the christians
they say they are a lot of this stuff
would self-correct because a lot of
stuff you're talking about
has no humility in it
we couldn't say i'm great and wonderful
now this if you really truly had an
accurate estimation of your christian
self
that's why this irritates me when people
will be like oh
he don't deserve you dead and a half the
time i'm talking about my tick tock
following or um
i don't know just in general girls
always say that to each other but you
have no idea how a girl is in a
relationship so you have no idea who
deserves you and
like genuinely
but we don't say that we don't sit in
the pulpit because the pastor's got to
keep the ties and offense coming
men have been shouted down in the
community so much or even i mean
you've said you've had opportunity after
opportunity after opportunity after
opportunity with men
you've had an embarrassment of
opportunities and relationships and no
man is good enough
i just would rather be alone than
miserable with
someone because some of my but that's
where agreeableness comes
in hand okay genuinely this is genuine
opinion
i think that i can get along with anyone
now
i'm not saying that i'm the most likable
there's nothing wrong with me whatever
but i have nine siblings do you know how
many different personalities
there are in a in a 10 sibling family
and genuinely i could go out to dinner
and spend like two hours with any of my
siblings
and granted that's from the same cloth
but it's the same thing with teams have
been on over the years
getting along with people genuinely is a
choice that's a choice
my friends or whatever who have who are
in relationships i see the
ugly side of it i'd rather die alone and
settle
[Music]
you can't make this [ __ ] up
and here's the thing sister ain't nobody
gonna stop you there's a whole industry
that benefits off of black women
being single and alone because you may
be a perfectly cool person to work with
you haven't been argumentative you have
not been
uh loud cursing i don't think that's in
you
but the but the sad part the sad part
is your outcome is going to end up being
the same thing as a ratchet
loud mouth difficult to get along with
the end result is the same thing
damn she looks scared dog
alone death at best you got to go adopt
somebody else's children
because you could not come into
cooperation with a man
in your own natural life
there's still time i think there's i
still have time
for biological children yeah not much oh
absolutely
yeah you have time you have time man but
let's go back 20 minutes ago
you don't have anybody in the pipeline
in the process
no man of value is actively vetting you
to be his
wife so ma'am you may have
time on the calendar but you don't have
time with a man of value
be honest with yourself stop saying you
have time if you don't actually have men
somebody trying to engage you now
there is someone that has come recently
come back
into the picture does he want children
no he has children exactly godfather
can't make this [ __ ] up
because people don't go for 30 they
don't typically go for difficult to deal
with 38 year olds to have babies
he doesn't think i'm difficult
okay i'm truly not difficult in a
relationship i am
i am however you want however you want
to okay ma'am you're easy to deal with
but okay okay
maybe not elsewhere but still still
raising was being a stepmother or an
adopted mother
what you want or do you want to see your
own dna do you want to see your daughter
looking back at you with your eyes
yes don't give me don't give me okay
honestly
i think everyone would prefer to have
your own kids but
i've seen a lot like my parents adopted
a couple of my siblings and
it's definitely still a fulfilling life
if you adopt kids and raise them
like there are kids that need parents
don't give me the college answer give me
the truth
well the truth is what i said earlier if
i marry a man who wants to have a child
with me
that's fine this person i ask you what
do you want
children i asked you what you want i
asked you what you want
i don't necessarily want biological
children okay if you don't want
biological children that's fine
so while we're talking about i still
have time to have biological children if
you don't want still have time to meet
someone i don't
necessarily i won't necessarily be that
i won't necessarily die alone because i
still have time to meet
man while i was talking about kids when
i'm talking about you running out of
time
okay yeah you still have time to meet
somebody yes you do
certainly however
you also got to get realistic what
what kind of relationship do you want
with a man post 40 years old
do you expect to work until 65 plus
i probably will well if you don't get
married you definitely will
[Music]
unless you're independently wealthy
already you're going to have to work to
lease until retirement age
and i am not independently wealthy so
you will have to work to 65 plus because
your career path is not one of riches
i make good money good money is not one
of the riches
that kind of money right hey so it's
about it's middle class above but it's
not
right okay so
that is not enough money to administer
an elderly woman
as your body starts to break down post
50 years old
yes so
it becomes a matter of necessity
see why i said it's so complex because
so many women like yourself
want this fantasy instead of the
hardcore practicality of getting with
the man
to build something but no now you're to
the
now we get to the point where you're in
the or no man's land
and now it's like well what are we going
to do well
i got to try to see if i can find
someone who's willing to
partner with me and make a deal for what
to survive
just to survive to get to the grave and
not be alone because there won't be any
children out of it
and how do you respect you've already
shown yourself to be difficult to deal
with a man
because one man doesn't challenge you
one man is not going anywhere
all these men that you've been involved
with and everyone seemed to be deficient
in some way
and i'll say this and i'll get to the
next things relationships are reflective
that's why i said ultimately therapy is
a good idea because
yeah i've always said this if um
you reap what you sow in dating so if
you seem to only attract one type of
person
um you have to look in the mirror and
say why am i choosing that type of
person
or maybe do i have some of these toxic
traits um
you know fool me once that's you know
one
one time okay even two times but a lot
of times women have the same problems
over and over and over again
and blame the men the only common
denominator in all of your
chaotic situations are you yeah i know
the only thing that was
the denominator with me do you think
your father
has three daughters i never heard kevin
call him
you know like kiddish and wants to see
them unmarried when he leaves his planet
unattached to anybody out here floating
in the universe
he knows what that means
but so many women walk through life so
worried about the sex ain't good enough
he's not challenging me this and that
and every other group
women seem to get understand the
practical practical reason you need a
man
that was the nice way to say why the
second fiance
didn't work out i just didn't you know
i'm not trying to be rude
okay i don't need you to be rude but the
thing is i need
women to start hearing women talk about
these things
so the younger women can decide what
they want
because in the black community marriage
and relationship is not promoted okay i
think that's
i understand what he's saying so i
definitely um
[Music]
understand what he's talking about when
he at the end when he said like we need
to start talking about this because a
lot of
women i swear give the worst dating
advice like the women that tell
young girls to sleep around the worst
dating advice
do not do that protect your heart no
don't do that
um and like women that say you don't
need a man
terrible terrible dating advice so i
think it's good for women to like talk
about the regrets and things they wish
they did
differently so yeah i thought this was a
really good video
um do not forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification
bell while you're at it that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
and i will talk to you guys next time